by the way dude the elk's been delicious
thank you how do you like it i made this
american chop suey with it and my wife
gave a [ __ ] bad review before anybody
even tasted it and everybody just said
[ __ ] it like she goes it looks like
hamburger helper
i've been chowing it for like four days
like out of respect for that [ __ ]
health that you shot it's like i'm
eating all this [ __ ] i don't care if
it's [ __ ] bad
does it make you more aggressive what
no joe you [ __ ] lunatic
somebody gets in my face that might
cause me to get more
lunatic i eat a little bit of protein
you had to beat the [ __ ] out of people
for like three decades before you could
like chill smoke a little weed
put on your little rascals hat and just
[ __ ] chill out
you don't understand
i love him to death
but this guy is the most testosterone
[ __ ] filled dude i've ever met that's
why i love him i love him he's like
every guy i met in boston [ __ ] welded
together he's crazy the little rascals
hat will haunt me for the rest of my
life
no and this is what's killing me no i
never put this on no
joe crushing that
he's crushing that hat come on you know
he is you're killing it i love it
i love it you don't have to balance it
out i like it it's hilarious
i'm laughing at me too i'll never put
this thing on again no you shouldn't do
it i'm gonna stick it in the fireplace
you shouldn't know you're killing it
we'll keep it on for when the papers
come out in the morning extra extra read
all about it donald trump wins
in alaska
charlie finally builds a [ __ ] bed